the father of one of the teenage
suspects in an international murder
mystery says he believes the manhunt for
his son will end with his death breyer
miguel ski and cam McCloud are accused
of killing three people on remote
Canadian roads including an American
woman and her Australian boyfriend
police say they have confirmed two
sightings of the teens Janet shamlian is
in British Columbia following the
investigation search dogs drones and
armed police are now part of the hunt
for these two teens wanted in connection
with the murders of three people
including North Carolina native China
Dee's and her Australian boyfriend Lukas
Fowler police say there's been two
sightings of suspects cam McCloud and
Roush McGill ski in an area where they
found their burned-out SUV this is very
challenging terrain this is a large area
the Royal Canadian Mounted Police
believe the pair are on foot authorities
have charged the teens with
second-degree murder in the death of a
Canadian man a university lecturer whose
body was discovered about 300 miles from
where decent fowler were found dead the
canadian publication of Globe and Mail
reports the suspects are linked to now
inactive social media accounts that
share themes including the communist
icon far-right politics and Nazi symbols
the globe published this photo from a
source allegedly showing Miguel ski with
a gun the normal child doesn't travel
across the country fooling people
Miguel skis father worries his son may
be on a suicide mission
this story and the search have consumed
Canada it is on cable news here
literally around the clock
people everywhere here are talking about
it saying this type of thing just does
not happen in Canada Tony meanwhile the
search will continue this morning in an
area of Manitoba that's been described
as buggy swampy and brutal heartlessly
anguish on that father's face Shannon
thank you very much